c'était il y a quinze ans le 13 février
2006 ilan halimi a retrouvé agonisant
près d'une voie de rer après avoir été
torturé et séquestré pendant 24 jours en
région parisienne par le gang des
barbares
l affaire avait choqué toute la france
27 prévenus ont été condamnés
lors de cette affaire et le caractère
antisémite a été retenu et reconnu par
la justice
aujourd'hui dans le square ilan halimi
dans le 12e arrondissement de paris
plusieurs associations juives et
plusieurs associations de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme étaient présentes pour
lui rendre un dernier hommage comme ils
le font chaque année
et puis en hommage à ilan halimi mais
pas seulement à toutes les autres
victimes mortes à cause de
l'antisémitisme ou encore de toutes
autres formes de racisme et vous
l'imaginez bien l'ambiance c'était
pesant elle était lourde l'heure était
au recueillement et il a eu plusieurs
prises de paroles également c'était un
rassemblement statique uniquement dans
ce square ici le square ilan halimi est
le message qui ressort de toutes ses
prises de parole est bien c'est qu'il
faut rester solidaire unie et qu'il faut
condamner toute forme de racisme